it might be hard to put on a happy face
after hearing these comments actor and
comedian Marc Maron who plays a
character named ted marco in the
upcoming Joker movie made some
head-turning remarks about Marvel movies
and their fans during a recent interview
with Conan O'Brien I generally don't
like them because I you know I don't
want to be bullied into seeing those
look Conan I'm a grown-up I'm not seven
Marin appeared on Conan to promote
Netflix's acclaimed comedy drama series
glow which recently entered its third
season on which he starts as the gruff
but oddly loveable Sam Sylvia somewhere
in the conversation the topic shifted to
Avengers endgame given many were
convinced that Maron played the youngest
Stanley in a cameo appearance and was
just being coy about owning up to it
Maron confirmed that it wasn't him and
admitted that he has some issues with
Marvel movies he then offered his
unfiltered thoughts on the superhero
genre as a whole as well as the people
who enjoy it I think those movies are
for you know grown male nerd childs when
the Conan audience began to boo Marilyn
address him directly and said that they
should accept the criticism since their
quote in charge of culture he also
expressed frustration over the fact that
he has to take extra steps to see the
movies he wants to since comic book
movie fans always flug to larger
theaters and made the film going
experience and enjoyable for him now I
got it I got to go travel 15 20 minutes
to a smaller movie theater to see a
grown up movie with other grownups or
Brian then left when asking whether
Maron intended to come on the show and
alienate a ton of people which prompted
Maron to say that he may have overdone
into little bits
I you know look I just don't go see him
I'm not interested right that's all that
wasn't enough to stop Marvel Moyles from
going after Maron on social media it
wasn't long before the actor comedian
again addressed angry fans this I'm
taking things a few steps further meirin
tweeted hey Marvel movie fans stop
acting like outraised religious fanatics
defending their belief system it's so
gay if I don't believe let it go or so
I'm actually a big fan of a lot of comic
arts try to relax your mainstream masses
he added in another tweet good times
during the troll dance with emotional
baby brains forgot was an exciting waste
of time this can be anyone familiar with
meirin will know that this opinion of
his didn't spring out of nowhere
he's long maintained status as a comic
book movie opposer previously stating
during an episode of his podcast WTF
with Marc Maron
if I seem slightly condescending to
superhero movies and you think that's
rude I want to tell you this honestly
and from the heart I will continue to do
it I will continue to condescend to
grown-ups who defend almost maniacally
the integrity and need and greatness of
superhero movies meirin also condemned
comic book movies for pushing aside what
he calls real dialogue and real human
stories to the point that he feels there
are very few movies left being made that
are quote provocative and proactive in
terms of making you think and making you
move forward with your life and seeing
things differently what's interesting
about meirin's remarks is the fact that
he himself is in a comic book movie
granted that todd phillips directed
joaquin phoenix starring Joker doesn't
outwardly appear like your average
comic-book adaptation it's darker area
and evidently tells a very different
tale of DC's Clown Prince of Crime
it appears that Marin eased up on his
stance with Joker for that reason plus
the fact that starring in the film means
that he got to work with Phoenix and
Robert DeNiro who plays talk-show hosts
Murray Franklin Marin went on record in
the past to praise Phillips vision and
affirm that Joker isn't like other comic
book films Marin told NME in March 2019
I've been somewhat judgmental when it
comes to comic book movies and I've got
a little pushback in the press for being
a hypocrite
oddly Joker is not that kind of movie
the approach that todd phillips has
taken is more of an origin story and the
character study of a mentally ill person
that becomes the joker it's more of an
intimate and chrissie movie with a very
specific scope it's going to be really
interesting to see how it comes out
superhero films aren't everyone's cup of
tea it's best to live in that live and
prepare for what's apparently going to
be a comic book movie unlike anything
you've seen before when Joker hits
theaters on October 4th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
comic book movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]